oh no we have there's a tutorial to play
as a tutorial what's with all these game
developers explaining how to play their
dumbass games
do we have to do the tutorial yeah it's
the only option when you play a game
god what the heck okay
i wonder if i have to replay the
tutorial tutorial
oh looks like i gotta play the tutorial
okay the whole
picking up and pressing a button to use
something is gonna be tricky
oh actually that's oh that's dope
oh this is cool i like it yeah actually
that's not bad huh
oh god my face has been covering it
because it's in the
oh my god oh no one can see the game
literally it's in the top left that's
where my face is
so it's just a big gray screen because
your stupid face is covering the whole
thing
my face isn't stupid by the way i want
to mention your big
idiot face oh man the train overheats
well how am i gonna i can't but if
there's no rocks i can't make
bridge if there's no rock oh you don't
need rocks for the bridge dude you just
need wood for the bridge don't worry
i'm very stupid oh my train died
wait train no okay well your train died
i finished my tutorial
why would it start to burn why would it
do that
i can't get to that why what do you mean
why wouldn't it why would it
why wouldn't it i think it's what he
said yeah why wouldn't it
why wouldn't it be good i wouldn't hit
why why wouldn't
why wouldn't it oh god oh god it's ah
ah this doesn't make any sense why would
this train just light on you all right
mark
two minute break i'm gonna go get some
liquids to drink
i will be right back when we come back
we start the game everyone done with the
tutorial and then whatnots
okay
oh oh ah
it's dead are you excited for this part
yeah actually no i think this is gonna
be cool
but wherever the hell bob went off to
bob
bob bob
it is september bob
oh hey it works wow do we want to turn
on
checkpoints or something or no man i'm
assuming
wait you're the guy you're the guy
change it right now just just click it
you know
yeah just frick it listen or
quick mode let's just quick to see what
it's like and then
and then figure out where it goes i kind
of like this ui
it's kind of adorable yeah
oh this is much bigger than all that
enemies
oh why is everything dark why is it dark
oh because there was information on the
screen uh
uh we need to build a bridge to get this
wood okay
why do we need that wood when we've got
all the trees
oh hey oh what's that noise
oh [ __ ] i think the train's about to
choose why is it about to choo choo
we're not even close to right
it keeps it keeps going that's the thing
what do you what do you mean
it keeps going what do you mean uh do i
put
them here is this where we're putting
them yeah yeah so we need to go
we can go where i see it needs to be a
bridge it needs to be a bridge okay
okay i i need one of those woods to
continue this bridge
who's got the axe i'm not maxing get
some wood get you some wood
oh what did that upgrade do exactly i
think it's something we get at the end
of the level if we win
music much louder than it was in the
menu what is that what is that
mysterious jamming on right now what's
the electricity all about
do we have a bucket do we have a bucket
yeah yeah it's about to be hey they're
stealing our wood
hey what the hell bob we need that wood
on the oh oh no
rail rail rail rail rail rail rail get
out my way
yeah well wait we don't have a way to
get in front of the train now we got to
keep building bridges
go go go go go go do the thing do the
thing all right bridge me
i don't have an axe someone with wood
build a bridge i have to go the long way
around
wait i'm bringing the pickaxe i'm gonna
make it i'm gonna make it i'm going to
make it i'm going to be oh
yeah all right all right i'll continue
building the bridge i'll continue
building the bridge
okay i'm bringing the uh okay you first
then
would you can stack i'm bringing i'm
bringing what i'm
okay we might need we no no no don't
touch the wood get out of here give me
that my wood
let me go you i can i kill him can i
murder him
no i didn't seem to be able to hurt him
in any way i want to hurt him
oh yeah make that lay the track baby lay
that track baby
weigh that would be the one lay
the wheel man we're laying so good
all right lay me there we go
there we go there we go
it's going and coming where did it come
from where did it go where did it come
from
i don't know
or they just stack automatically oh wow
oh
it really speeds up when you get there
oh cool oh my god
okay everything's fine all right cool
unreal well this is easy
oh that was actually it what oh we did
it
yeah that's the quick mode it's quick
you guys up for a real challenge um what
what's the real challenge what is what
is the real challenge
oh do you remember no why would i run 21
of september what what it's the first
of september oh oh
upgrade get out here what is it make a
path use the pickaxe to make a path you
psychopath
look at this oh my god all the freaking
tutorials i hate them
all right uh iron in iron or stone i
don't know what it is
i'm gonna clear up can we get those
bolts down there can you guys make a
bridge to get those bolts
bridge bolts what are the bolts to
uh they allow you to get upgrades for
your train between like levels
upgrades for the train what does the
train get upgraded faster we don't want
faster
well like it can make the tracks faster
you can hold more materials on the train
oh okay well that's right who's got the
x you got the x i'm just chopping this
whole forest
okay do you want to help make a path
through this forest and kill some of
these cows
oh you i can kill the cows how do you
kill the cows
yeah i'm talking about [ __ ] oh my god
oh my god oh that's not good oh that's
fine what are you talking about it's
fine
dude we're killing them i thought it was
pretty obvious
i'm gonna start laying track i guess
yeah does it
start going when you lay track or is it
going right now but it's so slow it's
almost imperceptible
we're on the very first level so i think
it amps up in speed like each level
okay that seems fake oh it's gonna go oh
oh it's gonna go
it's going it's chewing it's going now
what are you what are you doing to me
i don't know i'm trying to help it's i
got the whole it's okay
you gotta worry about it all right well
you're not getting the murderer
whatever you don't worry about this ah
the cows are dead except for one because
i wanted it to
remember its loss and suffer for it we
do need more wood where does that
actually
it's it's common oh my god
plenty of wood look i like me a good
piece of lumber
hi yeah i'm here we have a bucket this
time we do have a bucket that's good
is that good does that mean it can light
on fire i assume so
it's fine this is fine what was the
thing in the other train where it had
like electricity going i didn't know
what that was all about
i don't honestly know what you're
talking about yeah i didn't i didn't see
that i guess
oh the color of the little tanker
changes and it gets
spicier the the hotter it is
i see i see i see going on here
see how this tank thing is blue right
now uh it was like it gets like
red or it gets like pink as it gets it
gets spicier yeah
uh yeah i got the rocks don't worry
about that dude we're there
my guys done was done before
what happens if you stand in front of me
get ready am i gonna die am i gonna die
am i gonna die oh
i'm gonna die i'm fine no you're fine
you're fine
cool looks like you're fine i'm
apparently fine
oh stack size plus two
i guess we have to take that one first
what's a wagon
the thing that holds the wooden stone oh
no you can stack more wooden stone in
there to make more track auto pick up
commodities placed nearby
so you could drop wooden stone near it
it would pick it up oh that's nice oh
that's
lights up the darkness how dark does it
get
maybe i don't know that's the power
thing the battery oh
okay you put stone in there or iron or
whatever it is and it goes better
improve steam engine i don't know what
that means maybe it catches on fire less
i like the pickup i like the pickup i
like the auto pickup because
it's the winner strategically with the
two bolts we have two bolts
look look at the bolts it's making me
take this one up here what am i
making you take a new one like do you
see it glowing do you guys see the
tutorial thing on this hit a
get through the tutorial spam a until
you're done with the tutorials
oh hey hug spam a this is the guy that's
played the game before
there you go well i don't know why we're
relying on you wait can we reorganize
these jimmies
yeah oh you can oh daddy definitely put
it at the front
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah is that the order you
guys want this thing in oh
does that need to be there well don't we
want these at the front though don't we
want the
the manufactured parts at the front and
then like this guy next maybe
and like the water at the end because
water's for nerds
then that then the finished rails the
finished tracks will be near the front
makes
sense it makes sense he's got the brain
he's got the brain
we'll see we only had one more wagon so
what they'd rather replace or
upgrade oh it's the same okay all right
uh
um i don't pick oh we still got the uh
materials from the last time oh god did
we lose the bucket oh thank god there's
a bucket
is the train starting uh yeah train is
going it is it is
oh god the wood from behind oh we need
it i'm gonna
rescue everybody yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna get some more jesus
okay so we we do have to strategically
place it before it gets to
you know right right right right keep
going i need that wood
i need that wood to the right that's all
we got oh
boy this is gonna be spicy there's one
more truck we can grab on the ground
yeah once you get through there go back
and make a second lane for us
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there you go
you can get to the wood
all right i'm just gonna start cutting
bob whenever you need wood is here
i'm gonna come gather i'm gonna come
gather right now and just stack
make sure we don't leave that bucket oh
yeah god if you leave the bucket behind
i'm i'm working on it i'm i'm
maintaining the buckets
i guess there's more any more wood more
wood in a big line
common baby thank you the auto pickup
thing
doesn't seem to be working the auto
pickup puts it there and then you have
to put it in the bin i think manually oh
i see these two trees so i get through
the stove
wait wait wait wait wait wait oh wait
wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
thank you i told you to make that too
late
i need to place this okay
okay we're good we're good we're good
i'm sorry i panicked i'm sorry i
panicked oh no
i'm glad you did because i didn't see
what was happening back there all right
i'm gonna
place this strategically back there
whoever has an empty hand if you want to
grab the bucket and bring it this way
bob's over there he's got it i'm gonna
i'm gonna hit it with some water i'm
gonna fill it up i'm gonna bring it over
we don't wanna cross the water toward
the thieve wow they're friendly
oh excuse me
first oh god i will carve another path
through the
trees i'm trying to make everything i'm
about
[Music]
so like a restart oh okay
uh-huh ah
think of the auto pickup guy maybe was
not as beneficial as we had hoped
yeah that wasn't very helpful this time
we've got this this time
it's going to be dope this time it's
going to be nuts
oh if you didn't have checkpoints would
you just keep going forever
so well checkpoints just means like once
it's just once we get to a new biome if
we
fail we go to the start of that biome oh
okay
well yeah that's less risk come on i'm
gonna play some hardcore [ __ ] man come
on do you want to
mine bob you want me okay yeah i'll do
no i'll do i'll do the pickaxe you wanna
switch jobs
i'm sure that's fine i figured you might
want to mix it up
let's do it baby is it balanced for
three players or
can it be like an endless number of
players or what i think up the four
um i'm also going to either go down
there to a bridge yes let me go down or
bridge
uh let's go down let's go down yeah yeah
yeah that's a good idea
all right make it wide baby oh two lanes
you know it
apparently there's an achievement for
each player to mine a rock
so if you guys wanna you guys want a ham
dude i've already done it
uh i don't i think you have to do it in
this i think it's this specific attempt
oh you're right in the top left corner
there you see i didn't know that i
didn't
swipe switch or swipe swap me awesome
john
did we get the achievement that i cut
down i think yeah yeah you did it
okay we're just going straight here yeah
i mean we just need to go
left right yeah i think so okay
everything
is in order you can look how high you
can stack [ __ ] oh my god oh you can oh
god
i will make the bridge never mind there
we go
i'm just gonna go do we oh we have to go
up all right i guess i'm gonna go
through these cows kill those cops kill
them cows
do the tools automatically go forward in
this game or if you don't get it i don't
know
i i move everything just to be safe but
that seems like a waste of resources you
got to min max everything man
i'm just chopping more wood over here uh
because yeah keep working and keep
working that path
working the magic working yeah yeah yeah
work it don't let the
robbers out though you can't the robbers
out he
um there's a dinosaur in our game
oh you know i wonder if they can just
join with the stupid room code or have
to hide the room code or something
you want me to restart it and hide the
room code yeah we should probably do
that yeah we should do that
let's go okay
should we go down even though that's
kind of a hella path
i think we should go down not terrible
is there a bolt somewhere
i see duckies i don't see bolts which
which way down straight down here
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna make a path
down and then to the right so we don't
have to go deal with the thieves
[ __ ]
okay cool if you could bridge me like
asapish so i can start working further
ahead on the path yeah
uh do you want to go through the just
put like two or three bridges down here
so we can get back forth real easy there
you go
choo choo choo choo need buckets yeah
good bucket
i'm all over the bucket what is this
thing anyway is this like the
the boiler is the boiler blowing is it
trying to i guess
it's a steam train it looks like right
so uh i want to start carving a path
through the stone on this side
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we're killing
okay
that meant the track without the traffic
yeah yeah it's it's all chill man it's
all chill
don't you know what yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it means everybody knows but yeah
yeah
yeah yeah well made a goof that's all
right it happens to the best of us
you can pick it up just just just ungoof
it can you
can you pick it up yeah you could pick
up track oh you can pick up track
oh you can well hang on one second here
all right that looks good beautiful look
man
it's really it's really looking fixed
all right there we go of course it is
guys it's me we're talking about we got
like a lifetime supply of everything
i could make you mark i'm going to make
you some stuff oh my god i'm good
you're good oh my god i can't go this
way
i gotta get out my way dude you're good
you're good this part is still a little
stressful
i can help you i can help you look at
the stack i'm making do you see the
stacks
i am looking at this call me jimmy just
call me jimmy stacks over here dude your
jimmy stacks
i like that he keeps this stack
infinitely why is this new where's the
bucket you got that
yeah i'm a ladies i'm a lady's next
stone
my god yeah i mean the fact that you can
just or uh
consolidate everything into you know
beautiful
beautiful stacks it's so funny because i
actually am not pulling anything from it
because it looks too nice
i'm not gonna touch it it's just i'm
just gonna put everything in there so
you have to pull things from it oh no
man there's
there's enough on the ground that i
don't need to touch the beauty of that
stack
oh my god you can't place things on a
bridge oh that's kind of inconvenient
oh the bucket i got the bucket i got the
bucket it's oh good
there's a bolt down south coming away oh
there is oh yeah yeah where's my pickaxe
i got it i will get it i'll run i'll run
the train don't even worry about it
all right cool how do we get your giant
stack
up by the station so that we can benefit
from it in the future
don't don't finish connecting the track
because then the train flies just gonna
get it close and then we can go and just
start carrying we'll have to move we'll
have to move the stacks
once one stack at a time i think where's
the bucket
i shouldn't have done this it's right by
the the choo choo yeah
can you uh i got you buddy there you go
all right so let's make big stacks up
here by the train station
yeah carry it one at a time
it's three at a time you one or three at
a time if someone
planned ahead is it too many
conveniently
farmed resources you can't handle it
yeah well
exactly that's exactly what it is that's
exactly the problem
it's too many conveniently farmed
resources in an inconvenient place
where's the pickaxe oh don't let that
pickaxe go
what's gonna happen and the rocks are
gone
why would you do that who did this get
out of my way
hey guys hot damn
that lights on fire thank you very much
no no i was fine up there
no no no no no all right i'm gonna cut
some more stone here
because the woods pile looks a little
bit larger than the stone pile dude
we are why is this wood on the floor and
not on the pile
pilot you dweebs bucket oh god
oh no the robber i got your bucket i got
your bucket i got your bug what did you
do
wait i am not assembling this scaring
them away don't worry i'm not
assembling
i'll get some more stone then our pile
isn't quite sky-high
there's we can make more track and
prepare it for the next one too can't we
oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah dude bro yeah dude bro dude
this is why dude bro this is why our
team works this is why you're in charge
bro dude
yeah oh i'm just the muscle over here
you're gonna put it down
ready do it three two one wait it's too
late
okay good well done okay i'm gonna put
this down yeah oh yeah look i made
stacks
oh yeah baby stacks good stacks good
stacks good stacks
oh what are these well those are
different converts wood to iron or iron
to wood oh that sounds dangerous
yeah ooh crafting speed upgrade
honestly the speed's not that bad we
could put more in though this is a stack
yeah we can do the we've got two bolts
we could do the left oh that's true
that's true
okay do i just go plop it on i think so
oh hell yeah hell yeah what is that
that's like the next level of upgrade oh
cool
oh neat i bet the new engine lets you
pull more wagons
oh you're right you're right you're
probably right five wagons at the moment
like that so that the tracks are at the
front there oh yeah sure
okay this time we got it this time no
panic
no pain two lanes we're cool oh hell
yeah it's all there
no robbers the robbers are back
okay uh bob start laying track down
oh my god go
are we going down i'm guessing we're
going down make a call down take a path
just pick a pathway
you got it got this trying to get us to
the stone
we're going wibbly wobbly it'll buy us
more time if we make the train go wibbly
wobbly right
yeah technically yeah so we're trying to
get this stone over here if you want to
start carving out this stuff where's the
bucket okay
there's the bucket where's water we have
no water oh my god
oh god go back i'm going i got it i got
it i got it i got it nice work
i'm gonna get the pickaxe wait can you
can you we need to find water
we really need to find water we're going
a little zigzag
zigzag is good zigzag is good there's
water there's water to the right i'm
gonna make you past the watermark
okay i love it and i love you oh no you
can't break the gray rock i'm opening up
the path over here to get to the water
and everything can you break the one
right in front of the track right here
oh yeah yeah didn't mean that uh
start grabbing wood because there's no
wood over there for a little while
you got bud stack of wood well like
daisy chain it
no i wish i could carry bigger stacks
all right so we need to go either
through the middle or down along the
bottom
do we want to gamble on the bottom there
or do we want to build a bridge and go
across the middle what do we think we go
across the middle
okay yeah bridge bridge it up nice and
nice and good like so we got lots of
crossings
oh we need to start tearing up that
mountain so i can get to the forest
again okay
i will drop the bucket over here okay
you guys got the pickaxe okay whoever's
gonna start chopping wood then i just
opened a path to these trees
yeah i'll follow you in you're good with
this mark we need
buckets soon not right away i'll bucket
it right now and just
fill it since since we got access at the
moment hell yeah and i'll leave you i'll
leave you a filled bucket my good dude
thank you
thank you some some real strategy in
this game man tell you what yeah
and those robbers are stuck so we don't
worry about them anymore that's awfully
nice
you'll have a happy ending to every
story oh my goodness
this is panic inducing you're good
you're good you're good you're way ahead
of the game right now
way ahead of the game way ahead of the
entire
ass game ea is all about getting in the
game i am
ahead of the game i think when it rains
you don't need to water
i think it fills up on its own it's like
a turkey it just opens its mouth
i'm sorry it's like a turkey it's like a
turkey you know
it just opens its mouth up to the brain
you know what it is it's like a turkey
fall
you don't know what i'm talking about i
have no idea what you're on about sir
you know turkeys when it's raining they
just look up and then they drown
what no mm-hmm what no is that a thing
sure
i guess i think it's full of money we're
not full of that
i think he's full of peter malarke look
when it rains all turkeys die
yep you might not want to stack it so
high on that i think we need to be
further to the right maybe or do you
think that's part
wow yeah calm down calm down [ __ ]
mcgee
yeah this is going i'm gonna take it i'm
gonna zig it i'm gonna zag it
this time the world ends did it end like
this last time or are we actually at the
end of this buy-in i think it was like
that last time
yeah it was like that okay fire bucket
i got it i got it i got it i got it i
got it i got it i got it i got it
good good oops cut through here so we
have access to that water
oh yeah where's the axe there it is i'm
gonna trim these trees right here
okay so we do have access to this water
and also just in case the path we need
to go
takes us south i'll open it up yeah
dude i'm smart we didn't get any bolts
though did we did anyone
grab a bolt i didn't see one i did look
i did not see why is the stone literally
stacked in front of where the track is
going
i don't want to tell you how to do your
job dumb ass probably
you know so that seems like an obvious
issue yeah you know
come on guys let's get it together all
right we won't we won't name names but
technically the track can immediately go
down
whatever guys listen listen
we'll go easy on you this time but next
time
okay three two one replace that now
let's let's
do this that was probably very close who
knows
hell yeah hey we got two more bolts look
at that
hey wow what is this can we drink out of
it
everywhere animal you wha
are we gonna drink the animals we're
gonna suck them dry
yeah that's confusing oh oh we can
sprint i forgot
oh dash into it to fill up its charge
that's funny
that's funny you got to slam your body
into it if you want to
if you want to slow down probably later
on that'll be good
auto mines commodities nearby that's
interesting but we already
can't tell if that would be good or not
honestly the stack size is everything to
me
do we want to do stack size do we want
to save up and upgrade the engine
well we don't even have five of them i
only have three wagons yeah
oh okay well then yeah what do you guys
want i'm kind of curious about the
animal wagon yeah
what is that i don't know i kind of want
you for science i'd be
i'd be down to risk it let's get the
let's get the animal sucker what does it
mean by every animal you bring by
sure fair question i agree
all right so you gotta so if we find
cows you bring them over there i don't
know how to bring them
i don't either you can pick them up you
can pick them up
i hope they disappear into it you bring
it over and it's just like
and then the cow's gone and you're like
is there a straw oh there's a bolt over
there oh i'm accident
never mind clear cut right now somebody
acts i don't care just do it
okay i'm doing it okay i'm gonna i'll
lay trap
the track right behind you because we
have no space for this
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna open up a ziggy
zaggy area so we can kind of go down and
to a zigzag
situation for it i love that mark mark
mark mark mark
fix the loop fix the you made it you
turned i thought it was zig-zagging you
said it was exactly okay
okay okay okay that's what you say okay
okay that's what you said
i got you i got you i got you that's
what you said okay gg
here i'm just gonna put this here you
guys decide where you want it
wait wait you craft you craft the track
we've got stacks of materials so
we don't worry about mark mark can craft
as many as many rails as you need all
right
use use the space i'm giving you and get
creative i'm trapped on this side
because this tree right here so you guys
are right here i got you it takes like
five seconds
just call for call for a lumber man yep
lumber man
okay okay i'm opening i'm opening it i'm
opening it okay i'm not opening it he's
opening it
i'm opening it it's opened it's open
thank you okay uh i'm just gonna keep
zigging
yeah zag it zig it every which way we
got plenty of resources
that's why they call them weighty
buckets that's why they call them other
coins
oh this is only one player is allowed to
pick up the pickaxe
careful boys i don't know why that alert
popped on screen but you better not oh
god god i
just want to set this down
clear some of the resources out of here
before all hell breaks loose with the
collision
you get us to those stones soon too yeah
i'm getting there i'm getting there oh i
can no longer
we are zigzagged i can't get to the
water bucket uh
we have a problem here yeah the resource
piles are
really in the way break break break
yourself break some stuff
dude i got it oh
my god this is what i thought i grabbed
all right there we go get that get that
track placed get that track
yeah i bought it right oh got it you got
it good
we're good we good we good uh marx
somebody if we need stone that we have
access to stone down here now
okay so in the bottom bottom right over
here we can get some get some stone
action
oh my god look at that train
efficiency yeah we are officially out of
stone
and out of new ways it's got stone
bottom right we've got stone bottom
right
there it's dark i didn't see it we still
got stacks back here that i have access
to
we're good we're good oh we don't want
to go too far down there's robbers right
below
there was a bucket up wasn't there
didn't we see a bucket before it got
dark
up top you made it a bowl the bowl
maybe we're up top i think so i think
it's the top of the lake i think
way up there yeah it is there we have
enough wood
uh just build yeah nice nice good memory
dude
my memory that's why i'm so good at fall
guys
okay now i can see um we can avoid the
robbers
if we just go through the trees here so
i'm gonna open up this to the trees
all right i'm gonna stack some of this
stone just because it's a freaking
menace right now yeah this train's
starting to go kind of fast
uh like we've been zigging and zagging
as hard as we could but it's still
it's catching up someone want to grab
that axe and start working their way
through the forest i'm not sure which
one of you is that boy uh
i don't see it man uh right by the way
okay i got that you got you good
managing the train oh yeah i got it
you can zig up if you need to as well i
can keep opening this up if you want to
come up here and elongate it
oh it's gonna be so elongated
i had a feeling the word elongated might
elicit a response
dude you know how to elicit responses
i had a feeling illicit response might
elicit a response oh my god we might
die no bucket bucket
[ __ ] it oh no oh god that's a zig zag
situation it's fine we just need more
space it's fine feels fine i'm imagining
that we've got enough stone i think we
have enough resources in general we
might want to proceed to
getting the track almost done and then
like step making our stacks up at the
end over here
you all right mark you got that bucket
you got that bucket uh yeah you know
i got it yep uh-huh i don't see anyone
bucketing i just yeah
yeah yeah dude buckets in at
and trying to run back and start gather
the resources that are gonna slowly go
off screen we got all our tools we're
good here
yeah i got the axe pickaxe is over there
bucket is somewhere
oh you got the bucket i do got it yeah i
got it you got it i wish we uh there
weren't any animals here we really
couldn't test out our car i know that's
kind of disappointing i gotta say oh
there's another stack of wood starting
up there
that's fascinating fascinating almost
like i started at first
no no one of them is definitely taller
i'll decide which file i think is more
valid
thank you oh thank you bob for
recognizing
the true pile okay bob that
doesn't seem to pay homage to my pile
look you're both valid okay
that's why why can't you both be valid
why isn't there enough room in this
world for both of you to have piles that
are completely
valid just one of us is more valid with
me is anyone actually paying attention
to placing track
no my god
[Laughter]
it's fine it's fine it's fine fine my
guys my dudes my main mans
uh some of us are so busy trying to make
this a competition that uh
ruining everything mark i'm ruining
everything
mark no no that's what i said seemed
like was what you said i applied it
i'm not one for subterfuge i like you
know simple clarity so just tell me if
you have a problem yeah
you suck i appreciate you it's
interesting interesting interesting okay
all right we're one track away now be
careful
my dudes dude my dudes your dudes
our dudes our dudes exactly see
i had a big brain move with my pile that
wade wouldn't understand
i recognized that it was better to have
the train actually crafting tracks than
placing
[Laughter]
oh yeah no sorry i saved everyone
and you all were being
you know whatever it was you were being
oh my god
anyway you can't just spring
comedy on me like that
[Music]
bye